[Music]
did you hear farts spread coronavirus
and yeah that stinks according to
researchers flatulence is an aerosol
generating action that spreads the virus
through the air
this discovery emerges from Australia
but I'll resist the urge to say this
finding came from down under we went to
an expert for comment the evidence is
uncontradicted that the president used
taxpayer dollars to ask the Ukrainians
to help him cheat an election I guess
that makes him patient zero but it makes
sense if a sneeze or a cough can propel
viruses why can't air biscuits if it's
true then we finally have an illness we
can blame on the dog but this is why we
wear pants and masks which are just
tighty whiteys for the mouth masks are
now becoming acceptable accessories
along with social hygiene practices
there now behaviors we encourage like
not littering and not shoplifting and
not taking Don Lemon seriously you know
it's funny it's no longer weird to wear
a mask
it's weird if you don't unless you're
this guy you know congressman if you're
gonna create a mask on the fly make sure
it's not your spouse's bikini bottoms
yeah that's abnormal but in order for us
to get back to normal we got to do some
abnormal things because it's you in me
who are gonna lead all of us out of this
mess and we need to be trusted to do the
right thing because unlike our leaders
we can share the risk we can say let's
go back to work with protocols in place
and yes there's a risk the disease will
return but that is the risk and we as a
country share it and we'll act
accordingly see we can do that so our
leaders follow because the reverse may
not happen leaders are fearful of risk
because the media hangs all the
casualties around their necks but if we
share the risk the media can't attack
all of us a media full of hacks who can
see the future as long as that future
already happened they are the
hindquarters of hindsight and they just
can't stop this is exactly the kind of
chaos this president has brought to bear
on the crisis from the very beginning
now that we've got over 46,000 Americans
dead because of it
president though is peddling dangerous
suggestions on how to treat coronavirus
including injecting a person with
disinfectant it took a you know
colorblind gender-blind state you know
state line blind virus to sort of have
all of the president's sins from his
first three years catch up with it I
wonder what you think about whether or
not there's some silver lining there so
the silver lining to 50,000 dead is that
it really hurts that guy I hate with
every fiber of my being what a sad soul
to be so emotionally wrecked that she
finds a silver lining in mass death but
what do I know I'm just a guy who'll do
anything to work in a fart joke
speaking of fart jokes what stinks is
dumber than crap and his mayor of New
York yeah did you know he was shocked
shocked that inmates he released from
jail over fears they get sick ended up
reoffending I know a surprise I wonder
what else shocks de Blasio big things
are heavy
fire is hot no one likes him yeah this
tall drink of dope said it was
unconscionable that these criminals
would commit crime yep this [ __ ] on
stilts was relying on the principles of
thugs worse after he realized
downplaying the virus was wrong he urged
the citizens to narc on each other when
you see a crowd when you see a line
that's not distance when you see a
supermarket that's too crowded anything
you can report it right away so we can
get help there to fix the problem and
now it's as simple as taking a photo all
you got to do is take the photo
and put the location with it and bang
send a photo like this and we will make
sure that enforcement comes right away
Wow amazing
he's turning citizens into a modern
Stasi a surefire way to divide people in
a time of crisis who thinks like this
but thank God for Americans because the
response to this ass is distinctly
wonderfully American when he announced
the tip line to send pictures of your
law-breaking neighbors what did you
Patriots do yeah
flooded his narco line with porn
pictures of genitalia and also de Blasio
although it's hard to tell the
difference and so I must stop and say I
love you I do it's the greatest thing
you could do as an American America with
some big brother bozo urges you to turn
in your fellow man you sent him porno
shots if the founding fathers were alive
right now they'd kiss your feet and then
look at the porn now I know these other
outdoor protests are complicated on one
hand they're protesting government
overreach which makes them as American
as a pickup truck full of smaller pickup
trucks on the other hand which I can't
touch they're congregating which could
spread the virus if we slam the spring
breakers then we got to do the same here
it's wrong to protest without protection
but what's also wrong rich celebrities
who fastened themselves allies of the
working class now mocking the actual
working class you know who's not mocking
the working class this guy he put a hold
on green cards makes sense if you're not
letting Americans out to work why let
workers into work of course this will be
called racist cuz that's what the media
does it trivializes a word until it has
no meaning
never mind that halting new green cards
is what you do with temporary
unemployment skyrockets an idiot would
simply invite more people into a sinking
boat the stoppage actually helps the
minorities here Trump also helped the
little guy by demanding Harvard return
the millions it got in business aid from
the government so Harvard did see it
never hurts to ask or demand in public
still Harvard says they didn't ask for
the bailout so I guess the money just
wanted to go to Harvard but the media
ignored that story and I've had it with
them I can tolerate their device of BS
when we're wasting time talking about
budgets climate change and whether the
Oscars are diverse enough but not here
this is the future of America we're
talking about this eight transgendered
restrooms this behavior is selfish and
gross which is why you have to be your
own journalist focus on facts and not
narratives we are faced with adult
questions and every decision from here
on out carries a risk going back to work
won't be easy but we can't not go back
it's not in the cards or our blood
we have the roadmap and it's over rocky
terrain we know that the virus even if
it flattens can return America is a
battlefield and once we pull back the
enemy can again come out of hiding but
we can't remain in hiding forever we
need to come back in phases with options
that allow for retreat when necessary
or maybe just trust Americans to know
how to avoid hazards to their own health
especially if the hazard looks like this
man that does stink